right the growing debate over whether to
revive mask mandates
because of the coronavirus resurgence
the delta virus is sending infection
rates and
hospitalizations upward across the
country while vaccination numbers remain
stagnant
some of president biden's past
assurances about the vaccine
are now under scrutiny white house
correspondent peter ducey starts us off
tonight
live from the north lawn good evening
peter good evening brett and the
president just confirmed he is waiting
right now
to hear back from a 25 white house
coveted 19 advisory board about whether
or not
the guidance should be updated federal
guidance should be updated to ask
people to wear masks even if they are
vaccinated
we're going to investigate every aspect
of any change that could or might take
place
every time i hear that i wonder when
he's coming
the president hosted a large mostly
maskless bill signing today indoors
shortly after the white house disputed a
report in the washington post that the
biden administration may soon suggest
masks for the vaccinated the report on
it was a little breathless
in philadelphia officials warn about the
delta variant quote
it means all of us going back to wearing
masks in public
that's as vaccinated people develop mild
symptoms
despite what the president claimed the
various
shots that people are getting now cover
that they're
they're you're okay you're not gonna
you're not gonna get covet if you have
these vaccinations there have been
multiple breakthrough positive tests of
vaccinated staff at the white house
how many breakthrough cases have you had
i don't have more details on that i will
see if there's more we can provide
turns out that's a dead end no i don't
think you can expect that we're going to
be providing numbers of breakthrough
cases the attending physician on capitol
hill is hinting at a return to indoor
mass mandates there according to
politico
something a republican doctor who's in
congress warns against
there should be no need to retrogress
into a
masked up congress or a messed up state
so far cdc guidance has not changed you
should certainly be
wearing a mask if you are unvaccinated
if you are
vaccinated you get exceptional
protection from the vaccines but you
have the opportunity to make the
personal choice to add extra layers
but the president made it sound like
masks were a thing of the past let me
repeat
if you are fully vaccinated you no
longer need to wear a mask
that could change as variants spread a
lot of people got the vaccine
because they were hearing him say if you
get the vaccine you don't have to wear
masks anymore so and that continues to
be cdc guidance
and you can say that that's going to be
the guidance forever
i am not the cdc director i was
at an event in the east room earlier
today dozens of lawmakers very few masks
because
that's okay within the guidelines of the
current
cdc advisory and officials around here
follow the cdc guidance
to a t events around here could start to
look very different if that guidance
gets updated and it could happen at any
time remember when the cdc said
vaccinated people don't need to wear
masks anymore in the spring
that came out of nowhere right peter
what's the white house saying about the
new
ethical concerns about hunter biden's
upcoming
art show officials here brett are saying
that they
are going to have no idea at the white
house who exactly
is bidding on bidding up to six figures
on some of hunter biden's art
work they think that that is going to
prevent people from trying to seek
influence with the president through the
sun however
the gallery selling his stuff told cbs
hunter is going to meet with prospective
buyers
and that conflicts with what the white
house had said in the past
especially since we don't know what kind
of guard rails specifically are
there to ensure that everything is on
the up and up i've reached out
to that gallery for more information
looking
at some of that art just moments ago
peter thank you hey sean hannity here
hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else